thanks to curiositystream for keeping
legal eagle in the air get 26
off curiosity stream and nebula using
the link in the description
everyone knows police can't lie to you
false
[Music]
if you ask a lawyer a legal question the
answer is usually
it depends because it usually depends
the law is a vast and complex thing so
it won't surprise any of you that there
are many misconceptions about what
is and is not illegal the law is
complicated and it's easy to get
confused if you have no legal experience
but the fun thing about
law is that people tend to believe that
there are certain hard and fast rules
that are
unfortunately definitely wrong so let's
dispel some myths and correct some
misconceptions
and be honest did you believe any of
these things
like everybody knows it's illegal to
marry your cousin
false you can marry your cousin provided
it's your first cousin and you live in
one of the 21 american states that allow
it
cousin marriage has always been popular
around the world
gross but for hundreds of years it was
considered a relatively good bet for a
long-lasting union you think of
all the family that you already share
but things started to change in america
in the mid-1800s when states decided
that cousins marrying cousins was a bad
idea and
interestingly enough cousin marriages
weren't ever outlawed in england and
they are still allowed in canada
largely because the practice was
associated with the aristocracy
in america the situation was largely the
opposite cousin marriage was viewed
negatively in part because it was
practiced by people who didn't have lots
of money but let's get down to brass
tacks
first cousin marriage is legal in
alabama alaska california colorado
connecticut the district of columbia
florida
because of course georgia hawaii
maryland massachusetts new jersey new
mexico new york and north carolina in
several other states it's allowed with
some restrictions these states include
arizona illinois indiana utah and
wisconsin where first cousin marriage
is allowed if the parties are above a
certain age or
one is unable to produce maine also
permits it if a couple obtains a
physician's certificate of genetic
counseling
though note if you do go through with it
susan collins may
express her displeasure and furrow and
eyebrow but then allow you to do it
anyway
this is disgraceful but i guess this
so-called myth is actually true in
certain states if you live in arkansas
delaware
idaho iowa kansas kentucky hey kentucky
way to go louisiana michigan
minnesota mississippi missouri montana
nebraska nevada new hampshire
north dakota ohio oklahoma oregon
pennsylvania south dakota washington
west virginia or wyoming you'll have to
look outside of the family reunion
to find a spouse which brings us to the
next myth the reading of the will
because everyone knows when someone dies
you gather in a big ornate room and then
you wait silently until the executor
reads your portion of the will and
hopefully explaining that your estranged
uncle left you millions of dollars or
if you were expecting millions of dollar
surprise you get nothing
or you're left with just a haunted
mansion this
is false i'm willing to bet that no one
who is watching this video has ever been
summoned to a lawyer's office for the
reading of a loved one's will
nevertheless many people still believe
that when someone passes away there will
be a family gathering where a lawyer
officially breaks the news about
who will inherit money in assets this is
one of the most reliable plot lines for
a daytime
and nighttime soap opera i'm left with
40
they are the major shareholders
how did daddy do this to me the big
event always takes place in the lawyer's
office or old-timey library
and it involves the whole crazy family
all in one room together it's
led by a well-dressed lawyer wearing
indochino presumably who gets to do the
big reveal now you can't blame
screenwriters for wanting a reading of
the will to be a real thing it's
a great way to create dramatic tension
and there's a lot riding on
this dead person's estate i'm leaving
you my keyboard
i'm going to keep it in my room at the q
mansion please give it to leo
will someone walk away rich will someone
be disinherited will
someone unexpected show up will there be
a fight but here's the thing
there is no legal requirement that a
last will and testament be read aloud to
family members or anyone else for that
matter
all beneficiaries named and will are
entitled to receive a copy so they can
understand
what they'll be receiving from the
estate and when those assets will be
distributed but there's no requirement
that the executor
usher everyone into a room where the
contents of the will will be revealed
in fact lawyers would prefer not to do
it this way since we aren't trained to
break up fights like a bouncer at scores
lawyers prefer to fight with our words
not our fists and wound you with
a pen rather than a sword
so if there's no requirement for wills
to be read out loud where did this idea
come from
well a hundred years ago estate
attorneys did gather the family together
to read the will because
not everyone could actually read the
will on their own nowadays
we sort of assume that the beneficiaries
of a will are
actually literate but the main conflict
in movies and tv shows involving wills
is
whether someone will be disinherited and
this is definitely a source of conflict
in the real world and since most states
usually have a very strict time frame
for contesting a will
it can be to everyone's advantage to
start the clock by notifying
disinherited heirs earlier rather than
later
this is actually what happened when
president trump's father died because
it's 2020 and everything involves donald
trump these days fred trump donald
trump's father amended his will to
disinherit mary trump and fred trump iii
the descendants of fred trump jr who
died when he was 46.
mary and fred were cut out of a 20 share
of their grandfather's estate
that they might have received had their
father lived the other fred trump
grandchildren are in line to inherit
their parents full shares in fred
trump's estate now the trump children
including donald told tax authorities
that dan's properties were worth around
41 million
at the time of his death the new york
times reported that the true value was
closer to one billion dollars which
obviously is a lot of money to be
disinherited from fred iii
and mary filed a will contest nine
months later which brings us to the next
legal misconception because everyone
knows if you go into a casino and you
start counting cards
you can be arrested because counting
cards is illegal
false counting cards while playing
blackjack though widely considered to be
illegal
is not really you're just playing the
game that the casino is offering at a
much higher level than they're expecting
there is no
local state or federal law that makes
counting cards against the law
generally the way it works in blackjack
is that it's more favorable for the
player when there are more aces
and cards that are valued at 10 the tens
jacks queens and kings
remaining in the shoe so card counting
is simply using a system to keep track
of the ratio of low cards to high cards
and if you have a halfway decent memory
you can teach yourself to do this by
tracking the changing imbalance of big
and small cards in a diminishing deck
and since you're just using your brain
this is perfectly fine
there's even a court case making it
legal at least in new jersey because
everything is legal in new jersey the
new jersey supreme court has ruled that
players cannot be discriminated against
based on their playing skills even if
they are caught counting cards
counting cards does not violate the new
jersey casino control act however
counting cards becomes problematic if
you're using a device to count cards or
you have friends who are tipping you off
though if you're playing in nevada the
rules are a bit different there's no
nevada law against counting cards
but the casinos also have free rein to
remove people as they see
fit casinos are private property they
can remove just about anyone for any
reason
so if you're caught counting cards in
vegas even with your brain
you can expect the pit boss to pull you
aside and prohibit you from playing
blackjack
which takes us to the next legal
misconception because everybody knows
that you have to wait 24 hours to report
a missing person
even if you know that your loved one is
missing you were there when
the dark van pulled up beside your loved
one the sliding door opened and some
henchmen who were wearing black shirts
that said henchmen on it grabbed your
loved one and threw them in the van and
drove off and then of course you go to
the local chief of police who
of course you trust because he's been a
long time family friend
and you confide and say that you saw
them abducts your loved one and he says
look i'm sorry i believe you but i can't
do anything about it because you have to
wait 24 hours before you can report a
missing person
and it sounds reasonable it sounds like
a law that actually exists but of course
your long-time family friend has been in
on the conspiracy from the very
beginning so obviously then you have to
take the law in your own hands because
you waited 24 hours to report a missing
person
but that is false
[Laughter]
a lot of people think that if a person
is missing you have to wait 24 hours to
report it to the authorities but in
reality there is no state or federal law
requiring police departments to wait 24
hours before investigating a missing
person's case
in fact in 1990 the crime control act
became law which mandated that all law
enforcement agencies immediately report
a missing child
under the age of 18 to the national
crime information center at the
department of justice
and in 2003 president george w bush
signed the protect
act which included suzanne's law raising
the age to 21. so anyone under that age
could be reported to the national
database immediately suzanne lyall was a
19 year old college student who
disappeared in 1998 and
when lyle's disappearance was reported
to campus police officers told her
parents that brief absences were not
uncommon for college students
so they shouldn't worry since she would
probably turn up she was
unfortunately never seen again and as
suzanne's case demonstrates there is
some truth to the myth that for missing
adults police departments once had
waiting periods before they would take a
missing person's report
the common belief was that most people
who seem to be missing actually return
fairly quickly
today most law enforcement agencies have
reversed course even for
adults this is partly because in the age
of the cell phone most people are
reachable
relatively quickly and if they don't
respond something
is likely to be wrong but to sum it up
when an adult or child goes missing
it should be immediately reported and
under suzanne's law
federal state and local law enforcement
must report all missing persons up to
the age of 21 to the doj without delay
and the police are obligated to
investigate right away which takes us to
the next legal misconception which is
that if you are
accused of a crime everyone knows that
you can't be convicted on circumstantial
evidence alone
because everyone knows circumstantial
evidence is weak and can't lead to a
conviction
false criminal defendants often tell
their lawyers all the prosecutors have
on me is
circumstantial evidence and you can't
convict on circumstantial evidence alone
but the number one mistake people make
about criminal law and
frankly civil law for that matter is
that circumstantial evidence is not
enough to convict
but there's no law saying that and in
fact the law says the absolute opposite
the standard of proof in criminal trials
is beyond a reasonable doubt and that
means that the prosecution must prove
that the defendant is guilty of a crime
charged to the extent that
no reasonable person could have a
reasonable doubt that the defendant is
guilty and the prosecution can prove
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt by
building a case through direct evidence
circumstantial evidence or
a combination of both direct evidence
directly shows
the defendant's guilt requiring no
inference whatsoever direct evidence
would be a video
showing someone is killing the victim or
a witness testifying that they saw the
person murdering that victim
circumstantial evidence on the other
hand is indirect evidence that may lead
to the inference that the defendant
committed a crime even though there's no
direct proof
the key word here is inference since
circumstantial evidence allows jurors to
infer facts that the prosecutors don't
have direct evidence to prove
but circumstantial evidence can be
extremely strong
even dna evidence considered some of the
strongest evidence out there
is circumstantial for example if a
criminal defendant had
traces of the victim's blood in their
apartment
then you might make the inference that
that person was in fact the killer
though
it's possible that that blood could have
gotten there under other circumstances
so
that might be extremely strong evidence
but there might be an explanation for it
that's
circumstantial evidence of course not
all circumstantial evidence is created
equal
some is stronger and weaker than others
and this is where jury discretion comes
in it's up to the individual jurors to
weigh the importance of
each piece of evidence and then decide
together whether the prosecution has
proven its case for example there was no
direct
evidence that infamous casey anthony
killed her daughter kaylee but
the prosecution thought they had strong
circumstantial evidence their theory was
that casey used chloroform to suffocate
her child
however the child's body was so badly
decomposed that there was no definitive
determination of the cause of death the
prosecution
had evidence that someone in anthony's
household had done in
internet searches for information on
chloroform and traces of chloroform were
found in the trunk of anthony's car
and the prosecution hoped that the jury
would draw an inference that the
internet search in chloroform traces
along with the fact that anthony didn't
report her child was missing for a month
proved that she killed her child and of
course a lot of people believed that as
well
however the jury did not think that that
was enough to prove that
casey anthony killed her daughter beyond
a reasonable doubt if the same case was
tried to ten different juries
it'd be interesting to know how many of
them would have drawn the same
conclusion but that's not how our system
works you can be convicted
or found not guilty based on
circumstantial evidence alone but that
brings us to the next legal
misconception which is that
everybody knows that if you're doing
something illegal and you think you
might be interacting with an undercover
cop
you should ask them if they are a police
officer because everyone knows
police can't lie to you false
our final misconception is that police
cannot lie to you during an
interrogation
actually they absolutely can use
deception there's actually a supreme
court case on it in fraser versus cut
the supreme court
affirmed the legality of deceptive
interrogation tactics
police in that case got a tip that
martin frazier a 20 year old u.s marine
might be involved in the murder of
russell anton marlux frazier along with
his cousin
jerry lee rawls were seen in a bar with
the victim before the murder
during the interrogation the police
falsely informed frasier that rawls had
already confessed
and implicated him in the murder
fragrance denied any involvement in the
crime and suggested speaking with an
attorney but
police continued to question him police
got frazier to confess
this confession was used against him at
trial and he was convicted of murder
rawls also pleaded guilty to the same
offense the supreme court rejected
frazier's appeal stating that although
police misrepresented raul's testimony
that did not make the confession
inadmissible and later case law has
interpreted this as allowing deception
during interrogations
this includes lying about evidence like
fingerprints or dna however there are
some limits
police for example can't misrepresent a
person's basic legal rights
so if you don't know now you know now
obviously this is hashtag not legal
advice
but hopefully you know a little bit more
about what isn't the law
and if you're the kind of person that
likes to dispel legal myths or at least
lord them over your unassuming friends
you can learn about one more legal myth
over at nebula because everyone knows
you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater fire
sometimes even legal issues are too hot
for youtube because youtube's algorithm
can be capricious
which is why my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream
because nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad-free
and also experiment with original
content new series that probably
wouldn't work on youtube
in fact if you like this episode the
version that i put up on nebula removes
this ad entirely and replaces it with an
extended version that goes into the myth
of yelling fire in a crowded theater and
actually
due to popular demand almost all the
videos that i put up on nebula are both
ad-free and have an extended discussion
they're also released early before the
youtube version goes live nebula
features lots of youtube's top
educational-ish creators like lindsey
ellis thomas frank and charles the
coconut with his sidekick patrick
willems this is charles
my new friend we also get to collaborate
in ways that wouldn't work on youtube
like tom scott's amazing game show money
where he pits a bunch of famous
youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
either work together
or profit individually it is
ridiculously good so what does this have
to do with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet they love
educational content and educational
creators and we worked out a deal where
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
a link in the description
you also get a nebula subscription for
free and to be clear that nebula
subscription is not a trial it's free
for as long as you're a curiosity stream
member
and for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering 26
off of their annual plans that's less
than 15
per year for both curiosity stream and
nebula
and because i'm a lawyer i made sure
that 26 off is by contract
the best deal you will find anywhere for
this bundle and since we've gotta stay
inside anyway i'm sure you'd love
watching curiositystream's awesome
documentaries and watch tom scott
torture your favorite youtubers on
nebula so if you click the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly
for just 14.79 per year just click on
the link in the description or go to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle clicking on that link really
helps out this channel so
do you agree with my analysis about
legal myths leave your objections in the
comments and
check out this playlist with all of my
other irreverent discussions of the law
including
crazy stuff that's happening on reddit
and my real lawyer reactions to a bunch
of crazy movies about the law so
click on this link and i'll see you in
court